former acting attorney general Matt
Whittaker is with us along with the
author of The Trial of the Century Fox
News legal analyst Greg Jarrett and
author of get Trump best seller Harvard
Law Professor Alan dershowitz Matt let
me start with you a cataclysmic event
for Joe Biden explained
well this is a game changer because you
know right now we've only seen the smoke
and you know there's a lot of folks that
believe Joe Biden is really his entire
family has profited immensely from his
public service but this would be
concrete evidence that would point to
actual bribery actual payments from
foreign governments to affect U.S policy
and that to me is an absolute Game
Changer Sean all right let me ask you
Professor dershowitz
um you had said that the Republicans
probably now have every right even
obligation open an impeachment uh
hearing about this now we know the FBI
director has not been cooperating with
James Comer's committee we know now that
he selectively redacted information that
was pertinent and key especially
mentioning the possibility that there
are 17 tapes held by a barisma executive
15 with Hunter two with Joe Biden as an
insurance insurance policy should
something go wrong I don't think you'd
hold on to tapes unless they were
incriminating to you
of course not but we still have to apply
the presumption of innocence even in the
context I agree all right but but I'd
like to know why the FBI has not been
cooperative
no they should be cooperative and if
there is evidence of bribery that is an
impeachable offense onto the
Constitution unlike what Donald Trump
was impeached for which were not
impeachable offenses but there has to be
transparency that's why I also want the
trial of Donald Trump to be televised I
think today's hearing should have been
televised we have to know how our
justice system is operating half the
country doesn't trust our justice system
and the idea that we have probably the
most important trial in modern American
history hidden from the public view will
simply raise the question again what do
they have to hide you talk about what
about ISM you know in my book get Trump
I have a whole chapter on what about ISM
it goes back and it's not you're right
it's not what about ISM it's equal
protection of the law the special
prosecutor said there's one law and it
applies to everybody but he was tasked
only to Target and investigate one
person he well let me ask you though was
Hillary Clinton treated differently when
we just played James Comey 30 110 emails
52 email chains eight of the chains top
secret 36 secret a confidential but no
reasonable prosecutor will prosecute and
may I add that's only 30 000 emails that
does not include the 33 000 because he
said in that very same speech was we
didn't weren't able to see any intent
was there intent when Hillary Clinton
used bleach fit to delete those emails
was there intent to to obstruct when
they destroyed devices
of course every case is different on its
facts that's why the special prosecutor
should have been appointed
very specific question Comey said that
there was no intent
no I I agree with you that's why there
should have been a comparative they
shouldn't have been assigned just to
investigate one person they should have
investigated Hillary Clinton should
investigate it President Biden should
have investigated pen should have
investigated Sandy Berger and then come
to an assessment comparing the cases and
comparing the facts then we'd be in a
better position but he had the hoods but
to get up and say there's one law and it
applies to everyone well he wouldn't
know that he only investigated one
person he didn't investigate a problem
he investigated a person and that's not
consistent with the American approach to
equal justice under law and and Greg
Jarrett I mean this is if you look at
the timing of this that was July 2016
Comey made that statement uh again not
really addressing the 33 000 deleted
emails where I grew up I think we would
call that obstruction but that was the
same point that they were launching what
the Durham report said never should have
been launched and that's Operation cross
fire hurricane
and as Durham pointed out Hillary was
treated to one standard and Donald Trump
another standard but he said very
clearly that that investigation that
dragged this country through hell for
three years never ever should have been
opened by the FBI
absolutely right uh and in fact as I
pointed out in my book five years ago
the very moment that James comedy was
clearing Hillary Clinton and he had no
authority to do that uh his FBI was
actually meeting secretly
simultaneously in London with
Christopher Steele who was handing over
the first section of his phony dossier
and of course we now know that the
investigation had no credible evidence
the FBI knew at the outset that it was
all phony and made up invented by
Hillary Clinton so you know you're
seeing a dual system of justice here
selective prosecution it wasn't just
Hillary Clinton who wasn't prosecuted uh
you've got James Comey himself who
wasn't prosecuted he stole FBI documents
when he was fired one of which was
classified that he leaked to his own
attorneys who were not cleared for that
information was his home ever rated was
he ever indicted for that of course he
wasn't same thing with Bill Clinton he
had all of those tapes as president
Trump outlined in his speech tonight was
his home rated no the Department of
Justice defended Bill Clinton in front
of a federal judge and said he has a
right under the presidential records act
to have those documents including
classified materials so Trump's defense
is going to be they'll file several
motions challenging the indictment
they'll argue that the governing law is
the presidential records act which
supplants a general statute such as the
Espionage Act
all right last word Matt Whitaker we
only have a second
yeah well this case is obviously a long
way from you know the end but you know
just point out what Greg said there is
so important because the case law is
very much on President Trump's side
all right I appreciate all three of you
being with us Matt thank you great thank
you Alan dershowitz hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else